life I think that one of these things I
always think about with a rom-com or a
ROM dramedy as the case may be is that
we have to fall in love with either the
hair or the heroine as the case may be
we certainly fall in love with you as
Carol in here what was the key though
for you to her what about her may her
leap off the page everything that this
man and I'm not saying it does cuz he's
beside me and he'll punch me if I don't
but he I was so shocked that a young
writer he's so young and director and
editor it turns out it would have such
insight into someone's my age
we just couldn't it was mind-boggling do
you mean I couldn't get over that and so
he patterned this you know this play
this this everything was on the page and
because I've lived a long life and had a
lot to call on it it was one of the
easiest jobs I've had I feel kind of
guilty saying that but it was just so
pure and simple and without embroidery
and without over sentimentality as it
was just so pure and it just washed over
me that's what I always help I always
say that before I go onstage when I'm
doing a plane but the play wash over me
and and this piece really did and I just
have to thank him also Sam to look in
this man's eyes it gives you everything
you need so it was a really wonderful
all the gals I mean we just had a really
wonderful time was good chemistry It was
as if we'd worked together the forum
that wasn't the case and Brett what was
the inspiration for the script it really
came from a place of questions and
themes that I I think I was asking
myself when when I was thinking of what
to write I come from a place of
curiosity I think and empathy I was
saying at a previous Q&A and I think
it's a good way to describe I've had a
pretty good life and I haven't had too
terribly interesting of a life other
than just trying to make movies that's
not a very interesting movie I don't
think maybe one day it will be after a
long time in this business trying to
make movies but for me it just it didn't
make sense to write about me but I was
writing about things that I was dealing
with and things that I was thinking
about and those things were about lost
and about how you can't get through life
unscathed but yet life is a really
beautiful and an incredible journey so
it's about finding that balance and and
looking forward to everything as Loyd as
Carol says to Lloyd you're looking
forward to everything you're young but
it's like I think Carol realizes even
older people can still look forward to
everything and I felt that this this
character of Carol came to me to kind of
express those themes and those questions
it felt like that was the right thing to
do as a writer so we mark Bosch my
co-writer and I started started there
and let let it kind of just take us let
this character take us and I my first
film was about a woman and this film is
about a woman and I'm just I think I'm
drawn more to two female protagonists
than men because I just find them more
interesting I find them I think yeah
they are and and I I find I find that
women have had a tougher go of it and if
there's any idea that you have you can
just literally take the protagonist that
if you make it a woman I don't care what
idea it is you make it a woman it's
gonna be that much more compelling I
think when I go back to that in one
second because that's refers to
something that blaze and I were talking
about a minute ago but to bring the man
into the conversation Samri oh man the
real man say I'm something about Bill
that that I I think we all can sort of
associate with is when when you come on
screen in any in any role you you make
us as the audience co-conspirators I
think there's sort of a sense of you're
with me on this come on watch watch to
see what I do what was it about bill
that maybe added a new wrinkle to that
well never thought about that deal was
you know I mean bill was one of those
parts that I could not turn down you
know I mean I've always been a believer
that it's all on the page and he was
pretty perfect and I think the fact that
he died when he did we probably didn't
find out that he was a [ __ ] like the
rest of us
but every you know it was an opportunity
to just be a nice guy and play a leading
man for the first time in a long time
you know I've been playing a lot of
character parts lately and it was great
to have something like this come around
again I think his directness and his
tenderness with Carol was something that
really spoke to me and also having an
opportunity to work with the plies and
I've never met never crossed paths with
and the 50 years we've been in the
business which is always kind of an odd
thing you know it was of joy pure joy
and Brett wasn't too bad either I'm
still kind of mystified by that whole
thing even though I've been sitting next
to him doing these Q&A is for the last
two weeks I thought maybe the mystery
was gonna show itself and come clear and
I was gonna say aha now I know why this
guy wrote the script for how he wrote it
I still haven't got a clue but I'm glad
that he did neither do i man timing is
everything as we always say it really is
late something that you mentioned just
now is that that the role sort of
brought a reimburse for you in a way
that you said you said you know people
see women of a certain age especially in
Hollywood in movies or they don't see
them isn't probably more more correctly
stated but a movie like this sort of
brings all these layers to the fore of
what they're going through and the
stillness and the quietness in there and
the liveliness correct I think women in
general that when you get to be my age
are marginalized you know and there's
become invisible there's a real it's
really kind of astonishing I've just
noticed that in the last few years
there's and and so to have a chance to
to do this and this highly you know
three-dimensional woman was was
wonderful I haven't done I mean even
though I've done been in several movies
I've never had a lead in a movie ever
and so this so I'm not as familiar with
the film business as I should be really
I mean I just know that it's been
difficult from
remember remember meeting Leslie Caron
years ago and she said oh you'll have to
leave here when you're 35 you know this
because it was that back then there was
such a dearth of women's roles it's
getting better and I think the fact that
the baby boomer generation is upon us
that they're gonna be more demands for
films like like this I also went talking
about time you know we shot this in
eighteen days and the fact that we had
this guy at the helm it was the only
reason I think we all got through it
because he was so speedy and yet so kind
and good to all of us but yet in terms
of also the the speediness there's a
there is a sense in the film of time
unfolding kind of stillness and
quietness that's hard to write how did
you kind of go about making sure that we
were able to sort of see what was going
on inside Carroll without much dialogue
I learned from my brother who's a
novelist and from I think you know just
watching great films that you should
show and not tell and I think there was
a lot that we did say in the script that
I think works on the page and then you
get it and post and I cut the film as
well so I would look at it and I would
really try to take that step back and be
like am I just like hammering this in
for instance like there's there was a
scene that we cut at the beginning of
the film where someone says like Oh
how's how's hazel doing and and you know
can't see you know we say the word
cancer like oh but then you go back and
you go what she wakes up and she says
hey hazel you sleep any better last
night that's all you need and I guess
you just have to realize that less is
more if it can be shorter and it's gonna
pay if it can pack a 90-minute punch you
know or 100 or 120 minute punch you want
to take the 90-minute punch always so
for me it is on the page and it is we
for me it's like you're gathering
materials you're like a chef and you're
like gathering all sorts of ingredients
because you don't know what your final
three-course meal is gonna be so you
better have options so for me it was
about working with the actors letting
them try new things we did something
called the fun take on this movie where
when I was sort of happy I would say
okay it's fun take and why the actors
just it that pressure comes off of them
okay Brett's happy let's just you know
do something and try sometimes you get
really unique reactions or just a line
it set a certain way
so I think I'm very conscious of the
fact that it really comes together in
the editing room and you've got to have
those options and I think that's where
you can find oh I don't need this line
I've said I've you know I'm glad we got
it I'm glad we had an option in case
somebody watched and said wait what's
going on here but I think more often
than not nine times out of ten you don't
need it so that was I'm gonna continued
to do that it's got to be you got to be
very you can't be precious with this
material you got to make it if the
audience doesn't care about that stuff
and their audiences are really smart
so as an actress kind of interacting in
a way with the kitchen you're kind of
being still and quiet and still
conveying to us there's challenges to
that that I would imagine are manifold
that that don't present themselves when
you're interactive that you but walking
through a house letting us know what
you're thinking that's a that's a really
rich kind of kind of challenge isn't it
I hadn't thought of that I just walk
here I did that's good though seriously
she doesn't she's not thinking about oh
I better do this and I better convey
that she just she's there and she's in
the she's in the character yeah we
didn't have any yes so I think I've seen
it twice and when I we first had those
first rooms
I had great character and I thought
they've spoke eloquently to her to carry
Carol's character
I was very loved the way her set
designer and you put that together and
their lighting it was very it really
told a lot again without